Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson this week in a completely
confused and nonsensical monologue that maybe
said that maybe the reason covid precautions
are still in place in some states.
Now, some states have eliminated all covered
guidelines, but Tucker says we have vaccines
now.
If we still have covered precautions in some
states, maybe the vaccines don't actually
work.
This is Tucker.
Take a look at the clip.
Speaker 2: The federal health authorities
also recommend that you continue to wear your
mask when you go outside.
How long will this continue?
Well, according to Yahoo!
News, experts say it's, quote, not entirely
clear when it will be considered OK for people
who are fully vaccinated to stop wearing masks.
At some point, no one's asking this, but everyone
should be, what is this about?
If vaccines work, why are vaccinated people
still banned from living normal lives?
Honestly, what's the answer to that?
It doesn't make any sense at all.
If the vaccine is effective, there is no reason
for people who have received the vaccine to
wear masks or avoid physical contact.
So maybe it doesn't work and they're simply
not telling you have that we I hate to think
that, especially if you've gotten two shots,
but what's the other potential explanation?
We can't think of?
One, we know the prime minister of Canada
has decided, after thinking about it a lot,
that vaccines just don't work.
And we know that because he said
Speaker 1: it out loud.
Now, there is a lot to say about that, and
I'm going to say it in a little bit.
But in response to that segment, Dr. Anthony
Fauci appeared on CNN and was asked about
it and he slammed it as a typical crazy conspiracy
theory.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: That's just the typical crazy conspiracy
theory.
Why would we not tell people if it doesn't
work?
Look at the data, the data overwhelming in
the three vaccines that have been approved
for use in an emergency use authorization.
The GAO and GAO, the Fizer and The Moderna,
you had thirty thousand, forty four thousand
and forty thousand people in a clinical trial
with an overwhelming signal of efficacy.
So I don't have any idea what he's talking
about.
Speaker 1: So I don't actually know the best
way to deal with this, quite frankly.
Because if you believe, Tucker, when Tucker
says maybe the vaccines don't work, does Dr.
Fauci going on CNN and calling it a conspiracy
theory change your mind?
Like if you're in the Umbro under the umbrella
of people who believe Tucker when he says
it, or does it just reinforce your belief?
Now, there is an answer.
There is an explanation, and it's really very
simple.
We have vaccines that work really well.
They are over 90 percent effective at preventing
infection.
They are almost 100 percent effective at preventing
serious illness and death.
There's one amazing study of 700000 vaccinated
people somewhere on the West Coast.
I don't remember if it was Washington or Oregon,
700000 vaccinated people were followed.
About one hundred got the virus.
That's point zero one four percent.
Point zero one four percent of the vaccinated
group got the virus.
Three people died.
That's four point two, eight times ten to
the negative fourth power.
Go back to middle school math to realize how
tiny a number that is.
These are extraordinarily effective vaccines.
So why do why does anybody need precautions?
Why do we need any masks?
Why do we need anything?
Because as of April 13th, only 37 percent
of the country was vaccinated.
It's that simple.
You know, that the what we've seen from Israel
is that when you get to at least 50, 55 percent
fully vaccinated.
Then you start to see cases go down very,
very quickly, and so if on the first day of
vaccination you open everything, you don't
have enough protection, tons of people will
get the virus and many of them will die.
What's really amazing about what Tucker does
is he brings up questions that have really
simple answers, but he pretends that they
are profound and incisive questions and his
audience sees it and says, wow, yeah.
I mean, if the vaccines work, why do we have
any precautions?
Since we have vaccines and precautions, maybe
the vaccine doesn't actually work?
Well, no, the answer is really simple.
Barely a third of the country has been vaccinated.
That's it.
That's the answer.
And sometimes the answer being so simple actually
makes it more difficult to explain it or convince
people because people don't want to believe
that they might not understand such a simple
answer.
Many people, when presented with the question,
we have vaccines, but we have guidelines.
Maybe the vaccines don't work.
Maybe there's this.
This is a liar.
That's a lie.
No, we just haven't vaccinated enough people.
Lots of people don't want to believe about
themselves that they could have missed such
a simple, basic, rudimentary answer.
Look at the numbers in Israel.
Israel is now highly vaccinated.
They have about 200 cases a day.
Israel and New Jersey have basically the same
population size.
They're both around nine million.
New Jersey has 4000 cases per day.
I'm going to say that again, because it's
so incredible.
Israel and New Jersey are about the same size
and they're about the same population.
New Jersey has four thousand cases per day.
Israel has two hundred.
What's the difference?
The difference is New Jersey is only 26 percent
fully vaccinated, whereas Israel I don't even
know at this point what the numbers are.
But it's very, very high.
It's got to be approaching.
I don't even I mean, it's got to be between
70 and 90 percent.
I'm not sure they've been vaccinating like
crazy.
That's the explanation.
And when Tucker Carlson, you know, at this
point, I mean, dangerous is an understatement
for Tucker Carlson's rhetoric at this point
in time.
The white nationalists are loving what Tucker
Carlson is doing on his show, including his
rant about replacement earlier this week,
which we covered yesterday.
The anti vaccines are loving it.
Those against any covid precautions are loving
it.
He is really playing to with his populist
rhetoric.
He is actually playing to some of the worst
elements of American society.
So the difference is vaccination.
The vaccines work.
We've only vaccinated in the 30s percent,
mid 30s, percent of the American population.
That's it, folks.
That's the answer.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram
page.
Find us on Instagram at
David Pakman show.